hey everyone it's sarah thread sterner
sorry end comm and today we're going to
continue our pharmacology series by
comparing heparin versus warfarin when
you get done watching this youtube video
don't forget to access the tune free
quizzes that will test you on these
medications so let's get started what
we're gonna do in this video is we're
going to look at the similarities
between heparin versus warfarin and then
we're going to talk about the
differences between these two drugs
because for exams you need to know how
these drugs work to affect the
coagulation process what labs you need
to monitor whenever a patient is on
these drugs those nursing
responsibilities antidotes and those
teaching points for the patient so let's
talk about heparin this drug is part of
the family of the in direct thrombin
inhibitors so it indirectly inhibits
thrombin which is going to alter our
clotting process so how it does this is
it enhances the activity of a naturally
occurring substance in our body called
antithrombin 3 so once
heparin hits the system it's really
going to make antithrombin 3 work in a
unique way because it's going to cause
it to inhibit thrombin and whenever this
happens it's going to stop the
conversion of fibrinogen to fibrin so
we've altered our clotting process now
heparin works on the intrinsic pathway
of coagulation which means this pathway
is activated whenever there's internal
trauma to the vascular system now on the
flip side warfarin which is also called
coumadin is part of the family of the
vitamin k antagonist now let's talk
about vitamin K for a moment this
substance is used in the liver to make
clotting factors so if we throw on an
antagonist of vitamin K the word
antagonist means it works against so
this medication is going to inhibit
clotting factors from actually
using the substance vitamin K and how
warfarin works is it works on the
extrinsic pathway of coagulation so this
system is activated when there's
external trauma so some similarities to
these two drugs is that they're both
anticoagulants so what they do is they
slow down the clotting process but in
different ways and one important thing
to remember is that these drugs do not
break up or lysis an existing clot
that's not what they do they just help
slow down the coagulation process and
they help prevent / treat blood clots
now let's switch back and talk about the
differences between heparin and warfarin
first thing is the onset how fast does
heparin start working in the body its
onset is considered fast compared to
warfarin its onset is slow it takes
about 3 to 5 days for a patient to
actually become therapeutic enough where
this medication is working to prevent
and treat blood clots which is why
talking about the similarities these two
medications will be used together for a
period of time a lot of times patient
will be on this continuous heparin drip
and the patient will be taking warfarin
and why is that because it takes a while
for warfarin to start working in the
system and this patient needs to be
switched to this long-term
anticoagulation so once that patient
becomes therapeutic with her on our
level the heparin will be discontinued
will be stopped which is which leads me
to heparins duration how long it stays
in the system only within hours compared
to warfarin it stays in the system for
days now as a nurse you want to know how
these two medications are administered
heparin can be administered two
different ways through an injection this
through the sub-q tissue and some things
I want to highlight for you to remember
is how to administer that subcu
injection you want to remember it goes
in the fatty tissue of course
and you want to say at least two inches
away from the bellybutton and one inch
away from scars because it can affect
how this medication is absorbed you also
want to rotate injection sites and you
never want to massage or rub the
injection site after you administer the
heparin sub-q heparin can also be
administered IV intravenously and many
times through a continuous IV infusion
and if your patients on this they'll be
on like a heparin drip protocol which
will have very specific guidelines on
how you titrate that drip they'll be
increasing the drip you may even have to
give a bolus or you may have to turn the
drip off decrease the rate and it all
depends on a lab value which is the AP
TT that activated partial thromboplastin
time and this medication is weight based
so you always want to make sure that you
have a current and accurate weight on
your patient before you start them on
heparin because you'll be giving the
dose based on their weight and you want
to make sure you give them a proper dose
of heparin so let's talk about this a
PTT anytime you see that think of
heparin because that is the thing we
monitor for heparin a normal a PTT is 30
to 40 seconds that's in someone who's
not on this anticoagulant now where do
we want them so their therapeutic so
this drug is preventing a blood clot we
want them one one and a half to two and
a half times this normal range so
approximately that would be about 60 to
80 seconds that's where we want them so
if you get some test questions that are
thrown out let's say the patient a PTT
is less than 60 what does that mean well
it means that this patient is not
therapeutic on the strip so the drip
needs to be increased I possibly need a
bolus how about if there a PTT was
greater than 80 seconds well that means
that
they are over therapeutic they're at
risk for bleeding we're really
prolonging how long it takes them to
clot so according to protocol a lot of
times you'll turn off that drip for an
hour and decrease the rate now on the
flip side
how is warfarin administered only in one
way through a pill orally and some
things you want to remember about that
is that you won't minister this at the
same time every day and tell your
patient to take this at the same exact
time every day and some things you want
to go over with the patient is how about
if they miss a dose of their warfarin
well here's what they need to do if they
miss a dose but they remember that very
same day go ahead and take the dose
however if they remember the next day
they're gonna skip that previous day's
dose and just take the scheduled dose
that is due that day and to write it
down what day they miss and let the
physician know now with warfarin we
monitor the pt/inr level that is really
what we care about
especially that INR level so remember
that and the INR level is calculated
from the PT level a normal eye on our
for someone who's not on warfarin would
be 0.75 to 1.25
and where we want them for being
therapeutic on this warfarin we want
their INR to be between two to three now
test questions if they're I adore is
less than two what do you think means to
happen they're not therapeutic so their
dose of coumadin would need to be
increase their INR was way higher than
three what would need to happen their
dose of warfarin / coumadin would need
to be decreased and they're at risk for
bleeding some more differences would be
the antidote for heparin the antidote is
protamine sulfate this would reverse the
effects of heparin if they became like
too toxic and for warm
the antidote is vitamin K which is easy
to remember because we know that
warfarin is a vitamin K antagonists it
really works against that vitamin K so
if we give them vitamin K that will
reverse the effects of the warfarin now
with heparin it's usually use short term
with warfarin it's used long term and
heparin can be used during pregnancy
whereas warfarin cannot be used during
pregnancy
heparin some side effects that you
really want to watch out for is
something called heparin induced
thrombocytopenia and thrombocytopenia
we're dealing with platelets so what
happens with this condition is that the
patient has developed these antibodies
against heparin and how it's attached
with platelet factor 4 so whenever that
happens that antibody will go and attach
to that complex between this heparin and
this platelet factor 4 and this will
activate the platelets now what that
does is it drops our platelet count and
we can have the development of new clots
or worsening of clots are already there
so you want to be looking at that
platelet count and see if they have
signs and symptoms associated with new
clots developing and the sign and
symptom depends on where that clot is
like if it's a deep vein thrombosis you
may feel a red harden area on the skin
if it's in the lungs and new pulmonary
embolism they can have difficulty
breathing chest pain if it's gone to the
brain effective circulation there they
can have mental status changes so it
really varies but be on the lookout for
that another thing if a patient happens
to be on heparin for long term or in
those really high doses their risk for
osteoporosis because heparin affects the
osteoclast
and the osteoblast activity so watch out
for that those bone fractures
now with warfarin it we need to remember
some things about diet
you want to tell the patient to have a
normal diet but they want to avoid
excessive intake of foods that are like
green leafy vegetables because these
foods are high in vitamin K and if they
consume a lot of those and we're talking
about vegetables that are like broccoli
spinach kale things that have those
green leafy vegetables because it can
decrease the INR level which would make
them not therapeutic and another thing
you want to educate your patient because
alcoholic beverages interfere with
warfarin they want to avoid drinking any
of those types of products now some more
similarities that I want to wrap this
lecture up on would be some more
teaching points because they're both
anticoagulants some of the teaching
points overlap so they patients who are
on these they wouldn't want to take
NSAIDs aspirin or any over-the-counter
herbal medications without talking to
their physician because it can affect
the bleeding times also no contact
sports while taking these medications
because they're at risk for bleeding and
if they get injured it can be
catastrophic no whenever they shave they
need to use electric razors not straight
razors because the risk for bleeding
using soft-bristled toothbrushes because
the gums can get nicked and they're
prolonging their clotting so it can
affect that and you want to teach the
patient those signs and symptoms of
excessive bleeding because the bleeding
happens usually in unusual places so
tell your patients to be looking at
their gums you see this using a blood
looking at their ear and what color is
your urine look like it need it needs to
be the yellowish color it shouldn't be
pinkish reddish that could be hematuria
they're bleeding through their kidneys
or looking at stool does it look dark
and tari that could indicate blood if
they're vomiting what does that look
like does it look like coffee grounds
that can indicate bleeding as well so
teach them those signs
symptoms and avoiding intramuscular
injections because of the risk of
bleeding okay so that wraps up this
lecture over heparin versus warfarin
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to take the free quiz and to
subscribe to our channel for more videos